it's one of the last days of the cashew
harvest in Inga ray a region in the
north of Guinea Bissau Maruyama Antonio
Bonzo inherited her cashew orchard local
producers used to only process the nut
wasting most of the fruit but with the
help of a cooperative they can now
process all of the cashew because you if
we produce cashew juice we sell it and
we can earn some money since joining
I've earned money to pay for school I
have three children and I have to pay
for their schooling and from my own by
processing the nut as well as the
so-called Apple the co-operative Boo and
Dana adds value to cashew which is the
main export of guinea-bissau antónio
Pereira Bautista a president of the
board of administration for six years
also teaches local producers good
practices about cashew planting for us
there's been a change because now we
also use the so called Apple to produce
juice and honey we process the fibers to
produce food for our children and we
also sell some of our products as
cookies or cereal bars cashew products
like juice honey cookies or Jam are sold
in the inga ray region as well as in the
capital Bissau but the product most in
demand is still the nut looking to
increase profits the boo and Dana
cooperative provides training and
mechanisms to support producers we're
establishing a small savings and credits
bank for our members the interest rates
will increase their income we can also
lend money to our members so that they
can invest in other profitable
businesses for their motor technology or
Mariama Antonio Bonzo prefers to invest
her profits in education if I finish
school I want to continue studying to be
a doctor this year for the first time
the co-operative has fixed the price of
cashews in order to protect producers
and to guarantee incomes